welcome to this video playing anti-drone
anti-drone nope no name in there very
high rating here for in English for this
English I am and quite fittingly he's
playing the Trump very popular English
just took circles
thanks to amongst others
Julian Hodgson who played it really a
lot in the 80s and 90s and when he was
still active he's retired nowadays it's
an option
I think he's concentrating on chairs in
schools teaching kids so Bishop d6 Mike
will be three I have rock b8 okay I'm so
Queen b3 is no issue and there's c4 so
yeah Queen b3 nonsense nonsense okay
Bishop d6 will trade the bishop on
liking your Bishop g5 but not sure that
this is doing much yeah that's my malign
against the the Trump it's sound safe
sound solid
I know put this the big issue here or is
it a connection thing
oh not quite not quite sure what is
thinking about hmm it's not a huge
decision here I think am i disconnected
or something
nope I'm not he is playing Queen b3 okay
that's funny
yeah c4 Queen B so no but I don't quite
get it
um what is the point here Knight a5 how
is he not losing a piece then he wants
to I don't get it I don't get it
Queen B 795 this is really nothing nice
got to check on b5 of course wow I'm not
quite yet in in game mode self-camera
just to keep it simple here that that
was the idea who came so he had an idea
with that one then okay let's just play
quick for once stupid so this night
couldn't be fine interesting should have
played differently then yes I just
didn't see Quinn he takes and c5 in due
time
out four before what about g4 is that a
warranty for let's do this something
like CD for Queen takes f4 might be okay
I have some pressure there on the deep
horn yester an opening accident
d take c5 is a bit embarrassing that I
did not spot that yeah main point main
problem was that I was thinking before I
and Queen b3 is not working anyway then
he played it and I just I'd wanted to
play what I thought was good see find
then you see it's not working and you
didn't then just play okay let's play a
simple and rook b8 and it's just not
it's not a simple move was just a crap
move
hmm
okay
I'm getting some play answers pawn them
so let's see
Oh a night only four doesn't have many
squares than right and some but I would
have a shaky decision we place fancy
stuff probably correct correct but slow
fancy
where is he going now maybe nowhere even
h4 is a move
Jiggs if I think I can take g4 at the
enzyme that's not a big problem
so just damn hmm
it's still threatening to attack that
night it's going to e3 if I attack it
with a try which is not helping me at
all and the night when g5 doesn't have
any squares ugly
ugly very ugly stuff my nitrous knows
absolutely no squares it's great
anyway it's probably just terrible
anyway basically no matter what I'm
playing not sure about that one at least
nominate an f5 Fields relatively safe of
course he is much better but I'm not
sure if how good this is in comparison
to other two other lines check ok the
two points are too strong they really
are too strong
is good before and it's a real deal
oh yeah here yes it's discoveries as
well I didn't come I saw it before why
didn't I see you know city
yeah real City what a quite a bad game
out what a bad game my me chec
time warning check
and I super slow Mia can probably and do
something on time ever wanted
check-check
resign just a bad game and lack of
concentration and everything just
unfocused this long thing somehow
somehow somehow our disrupt my rhythm I
don't know what it what this is
one minute something for that move yeah
it seems to be pretty good it's also
what the what the engine is giving it's
not so easy now
maybe we should be six this is an
imprecise move somehow I mean it's not
clear exactly what I'm doing after Queen
b3 I went through p8 but I'm not quite
sure how to improve on that after that
really just more or less upon down it's
really it's really no compensation him
weird very weird and it was just bad
thinking process
I was thinking Queen B three years
rubbish anyway because of that and then
I saw that this works okay cool and I
said okay that's going to be a test
should have at least thought about D
takes e5 and I saw it right after right
after I made the move and he instantly
took them no really just a pawn down
that's very weird well I think after
that I'm just goes I mean I'm kind of
try to do something but it's just it's
just bad maybe I think around here there
were probably easier ways but it is
meaning those phones are too strong I
wonder it's really especially six a
mistake that natural move I know it was
one of those quick moves but still it's
very normal this is kind of
kind of 956 amazing that Queen b3 is
such such a big problem hmm
the compounds to go a 6 cm you know well
the idea is that after this I can't play
c4 as this is blundering blundering
stuff so a 6 then Bishop d6 what about
this just just to check an alternative
is this a possibility just simple I can
still go here hmm amazing how annoying
that move is amazing hmm well that was
good thinking on his part that he took
so long here to to figure Queen b3 out I
was really not sure what was happening
because it just looks like a completely
harmless position but Queen b3 it's
quite strong hmm so I shouldn't go
Bishop d6 a6 is better can I do this
actually or still Queen b3
yeah well this is better than the game
but still feels a bit uncomfortable like
this this I mean it's no big deal yeah I
get c4 and b5 in so the double point is
no problem okay so Bishop d7 is also
better but maybe really eight-six the
move that the engine was suggesting in
the first place so something and I can
maybe like let's just do this this is
also what I could have played actually
instead of I can also take here first
well the compass giving Queen b3 that's
a cool you know I actually think that
this position was analyzed by Boris a
broken SD for deviations book I have the
feeling in this position I think I've
seen before that's a funny resource okay
so this I have to really treat make a
mental note yet you to be careful here
with Queen b3 ideas it seems to be quite
tricky huh okay well thanks for watching